is Joe Rogan actually a conspiracy
theorist he talks about it all the time
he used to be a huge moonlanding
conspiracy believer and if you dig
enough on YouTube you will find Joe
Rogan's personal YouTube account which
is basically just moonlanding conspiracy
documentaries that he uploaded as proof
like 15 years ago he's kind of backed up
on a lot of those conspiracy views but
he does like to have conspiracy
theorists on his show so anyway we've
just published this huge video all about
Joe Rogan but we're also working on one
about the moonlanding conspiracy it's
kind of the crossover episode that
nobody asked for